damit werden hollywood wasser
murat vorjahr
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen zum
einen fünf minuten hat jetzt ein richtig
cooles video es gleich weniger ums
kochen oder ums backen invista ich bin
sehr gut kochen sehr guter bäcker es
geht um ein anderes thema und zwar die
setlist gerade auf der baustelle wie vor
kurzem auch schon wieder
ich bin in der küche her ich weiß jetzt
17 komisch komisch an aber so ist bei
uns die aufgabenverteilung
ich habe gerade die kids den
kindergarten gebracht und habe gedacht
ich mache ein ganz ganz tolles video
es ist was hammermäßig es passiert bei
uns in der küche vor kurzem und ich sage
euch auch die gründe warum also wovon
westen war ja anderen einkaufen genau
also ich war neulich einkaufen und diese
schickt mich immer einkaufen nicht weil
sie was braucht hauptsache ich bin aus
dem haus dann schickt sie mich einfach
weg und ich war neulich im disco ja ich
glaube ich in discountern normalerweise
geht nichts im discounter das ist einen
anderen gründe und bei uns im haus neben
haus ist ein discounter und ich habe nur
eine zutat gebraucht bin dann wieder zum
einkaufen gefahren weil ich was holen
wollte nur ganz schnell
und dann bin ich einer zieht kühltheke
vorbeigekommen als er natürlich geht
hier vorbeigekommen bin ich schon wenn
man die preise an hat mich so ein preis
irritiert war so extrem wie soll ich
sagen niedrig dann habe ich mir nämlich
zwei tiefe hin geholt und sind auch
tiefgekühlt so einmalig mir ein
suppenhuhn gewohnt damit ihr wisst was
die suppen holen ist ein solist 1 1 ein
huhn das ein altes tun dass keine eier
mehr legen kann oder nicht mehr lebt das
wird geschlachtet so haben wir die
renten problematisch gelöst alles was
alt ist wird geschlachtet wird als
suppenhuhn verkauft dieses huhn kostet
haltet euch fest dann weißt du es noch
92 eur 30
wahnsinnig zwei euro 30 und habe hier
ein brathähnchen das kennen ja auch alle
auch tiefgekühlt und dieses trat warten
kostet drei euro 20 das sind keine
angebotspreise gewesen wirklich nicht
das habe ich den preis eines huhns 230
und drei euro 20 ich war so irritiert
vor dem preis das ist wie so ein unfall
nicht wegschauen kannst natürlich
mitgenommen so ein 12 münchen nach hause
gebracht oder tom die jungs und die
sandy haben gerade gedreht und dann habe
ich die jungs gefragt was denn ihrer
meinung nach dieses häkchen kosten würde
und da war möglich die antworten
zwischen 7 10 12 euro
und keiner kam auf diesen gedanken durch
auch die sally nicht dass dieses um 2
eur 30 kostet oder drei euro 20 auf
jeden fall wir alle schockiert und das
hat mir gezeigt dass wir eigentlich gar
nicht mehr wissen also also allgemein
keiner mehr weiß was so ein huhn
eigentlich wert ist und für was verkauft
wird das war wirklich ein schock für
mich
überlegt mal dieses suppenhuhn zb hat
1,1 kilogramm und wird für zwei euro 30
verkauft da ist übrigens auch schon die
mehrwertsteuer inbegriffen
7 dann haben wir hier dieses braten für
drei euro 20 und das lustige an dem
ganzen fand ich eigentlich auch die
labels die diese hühnchen drauf hatten
und zwar hier bei dem suppenhuhn und
auch bei den brathähnchen haben wir hier
das label comet also sind einfach
möchten einfach damit sagen sind wie
hund und wenn gummihuhn 32 prozent
möchte ich nicht wissen was normales
kosten
merkt euch immer nur eins bei
kennzeichnungen das wort premium und das
wort gummi ist nicht geschützt gummiband
am meistens draufgeschrieben ende des
jahres wird die verpackung schwarz
gemacht damit gut drauf geschrieben und
dann würde das an weihnachten verkaufte
als als als delikatesse
und ich fand es wirklich den wahnsinn
hier gut drauf zu schreiben ich für mich
ist ein etikettenschwindel
100-prozentiger und was sind natürlich
auch total lustig war eigentlich nicht
lustig mich schon traurig 23
brathähnchen und das ding hat sage und
schreibe 1
viele kilogramm ja 1,4 kilogramm
und jetzt jetzt habe ich mal so ein
bisschen ein preisvergleich gemacht hat
man geschaut was kosten was anderes dann
haben wir hier domestos ist ein klo
reiniger der kostet drei euro 25
wirklich sagen wo mit drei waffen für 20
das heißt viel mehr als diese suppenhuhn
und auch mehr als party chlor einiger
war wirklich der wahnsinn dann mich
weiter im regal und hab dann kaugummis
gefunden und zwar die aus der dose
dieser weeklies diese mit kaugummis
diese extra kaugummis die kosten
wirklich drei euro 92 eur 59 das heißt
auch diese ganz normalen stinknormalen
kaugummis kosten auf mehr als dieses
lebewesen das für uns freiwillig
gestorben ist ein freitag war es
natürlich nicht
das finde ich wirklich denn war der
wahnsinn was auch der wahnsinn ist ich
habe meine geschaut was kosten bei
starbucks seine person café ja
eigentlich gar nicht schmeckt was kosten
der im schnitt und holt euch fest der
kaffee im schnitt weiß da was kostet
drei euro 25 also auch wieder mehr als
die spanischen 250 milliliter kaffee
wirklich für 325 wenn ihr sogar noch die
roaming-kosten überall noch 70 cent
extra
also da war ich richtig richtig
überrascht dann bin ich weiter im
lebensmittel regal gelaufen und haben
geschaut was katzen protokolls und zwar
schäfer katzenfutter habe ich mal
angeschaut ich kenne es aus der werbung
dieses katzenfutter kurses kilogramm
sechs euro 50 also wirklich der wahnsinn
hier kostet kilogramm möglich zwei euro
und des katzenfutter kost fast das
dreifache und ich finde es nicht der
wahnsinn hat mir noch nach günstigen
katzenfutter geschaut was fünf euro aber
auch schon wieder das doppelte was uns
unser hähnchen kosten würde und war
damit ich schockiert
ich meine ich bin der meinung du
brauchst kein abitur um zu merken dass
wenn man wenn tierfutter teurer ist als
dein eigenes essen also viel teurer ist
als doppelt so teurer als sein eigenes
essen
da brauchst du wirklich kein abitur um
zu merken hier stimmt etwas nicht
und
hab dann wirklich mit den jungs ich
wollte es bewusstsein erwecken bei den
jungs und habt eine tolle idee gehabt
und zwar meine idee war eine ganz
komische ich habe natürlich einfach
vorgestellt und zwar ich habe einen
buddy beauftragt das am nächsten tag
bildet doch mal zum zum biohof gehen
soll und ein lebendes huhn kaufen soll
ich wollte die jungs normalen leben
schon zeigen um die wundervoll dieses
jahr nicht ist und ich habe den ball im
auftrag bietet auch einen hut zu bringen
vom biohof der hat auch gemacht und was
dann passiert ist das geht ja nicht mal
jetzt
also wenn ich das was heute hier
passiert es jemandem erzähle es glaubt
kein mensch glaubt kein mensch wird es
draußen ist das alles vor
ich habe doch nur sackten hohen ich hab'
ich hab' ich wollte nur ein huhn haben
ich wollte nun haben mehr wollte ich
nichts
der karten gingen hier auf gerade hier
vorne und dann habe ich einfach nur noch
mit der kamera draufgehalten und habe
den karton aufgemacht und dann ist alles
eskaliert und ich kann gerne darüber
sprechen
ich weiß nicht aber es war grausam also
ich komme hierher um bei der fälligen
kaffee zu trinken
dann steht der kleine dicke in der küche
mit einem huhn
ich habe damit nichts zu tun
ich wollte in ruhe etwas tun möglich ist
ich wollte moniert was tun
ich habe wirklich gedacht die leute oder
alle kennen sie im raum mit tieren aus
aber wusste nicht dass noch niemandem
kontakt im tier hatte
[Musik]
sally verabredet und sie kam nicht und
ich habe mich schon gewundert wurde ist
eigentlich nicht so typisch und dann
sich dann instagram gesehen habe
ich wollte doch nur den hund zeigen ich
wollte zeigen
angewandt
falls ihr blöd sie haben mag
aber ganz ehrlich gemeint du bist
mindestens zehn mal so groß wie das huhn
hast du angst hast ziemlich erwirkt so
was halt mal hände
also wir waren acht leute im zimmer
deshalb werde ich den wahnsinn
die sail war nicht geplant dass sie
kommt dies aus versehen oder ein
geplatzt ich habe eigentlich das ist auf
der baustelle
die waren auch um 9 uhr hier und ich
muss sagen jeder hatte angst vor diesen
hunger habe es so einfach
fortgeschrieben einfach in den arm
machen wir uns ein bisschen was über
sohn des huhn ist total ausgeflippt hat
natürlich auch angst gehabt ganz klar
war nicht in seiner gewohnten umgebung
glauben dass auch lustig aber ich fand
es eigentlich von der art und weise
nicht lustig weil irgendwie hatte keiner
bezug mehr zum tier
wir kennen das hühnchen natürlich immer
schön in der verpackung zerlegt so brust
keule filets und jetzt kommt's mich ein
richtiges huhn
wir waren natürlich total aufgeregt
haben dass wohl natürlich dann
eingefangen das huhn hat auch wirklich
angst muss man auch wirklich sagen
zu meiner zu meiner verteidigung muss ja
nein sagen bisher haben wir natürlich
nicht geschlachtet wirklich nicht das
kann keiner von uns ich glaube auch
nicht als das ist jemand von euch kann
ein huhn schlachten und dann nachher
auch noch zu verspeisen
das können wir nicht da war die das huhn
nachher mitgenommen und hat zu seiner
oma gebracht die oma die hat nämlich
mehrere hühner und die eier legen und
sie verschenkt dann die ganzen eier und
ist jetzt dort und dass sie mir das
glaubt haben mir das video von bally
hier von seiner oma und das ist jetzt in
freiheit ja was mich an dem ganzen am
meisten gestört hat und zwar ist möchte
ich euch jetzt ganz eigen und zwar haben
wir dieses huhn wir hatten ja dieses
label gourmet was ich gesagt habe es ist
schwachsinn gummi und premium sind keine
geschützten begriffe die kann jeder
benutzen
es war ein anderes label was mich bin
ich irritiert hat und zwar ist jedes in
die das label initiative tierwohl und
das label initiative tierwohl das wurde
vom lebensmittelhandel hervorgerufen und
von der fleischindustrie also nicht vom
tierschutzbund oder oder oder und
anderen verein der tiere gerne
unterstützt sondern mittig von der
industrie und das ist ein richtiges fake
labels wollte man mal sagen
darum geht es nicht um die
haltungsbedingungen der tiere zu
verbessern
ein gewisses terror zu haben ist sondern
illustre riege rechte tiere zu halten
was sein label eigentlich
bewerkstelligen soll das ganze einfach
das heißt besseres gehalt
aber wirklich nicht hier gerecht sondern
wirklich industrie gerechte haltung
normalerweise müssen euch eins
vorstellen sind 26 hühner auf einem
quadratmeter auf einem quadratmeter und
durch die initiative tirol war es ja
wirklich der wahnsinn ist müsste nur
noch 23 hühner auf einem quadratmeter
und was ist eigentlich eigentlich heißt
das könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen
wir haben hier wird der quadratmeter
kommt einmal ganz kurz machen und ein
quadratmeter hier ist wir haben hier ein
quadratmeter und auf diesen quadratmeter
sollen wirklich 26 hühner
das ist wenn ich das jetzt mal so
hinlegen würde ich habe mir keinen kopf
mehr ich habe mir kein kein halsweh und
keine beine mehr dh 26 hühner auf diesen
einen quadratmeter und durch die inside
tierwohl ist gibt es nur noch 23
quadratmeter ist für mich natürlich
trotzdem ein absoluter skandal
und was natürlich auch der hammer ist
wenn man den leuten wirklich zeigen
möchte haye das tier artgerecht gehalten
dann das ding dann möglich zu fahren für
drei euro 20 14 kilogramm der voting
starbucks kaffees doppelte kostet ist
wirklich der absolute wahnsinn
übrigens nur dass jetzt ist nur ein
prozent der in deutschland zu kaufen in
münchen sind aus biohaltung der rest als
konventionell
da wird betrogen und beschissen wo es
nur geht die hühner leben ungefähr vier
bis fünf wochen maximum das heißt von
küken bis hochgezüchtet vergehen vier
bis maximal fünf wochen danach werden
diese hühnchen geschreddert die männchen
hühnchen die männlichen sagt münchen
oder hecken genau die männlichen küken
die werden geschreddert inzwischen nicht
mehr man weiß es nicht ganz genau wie es
ganz genau dass man das nicht immer
alles kontrollieren kann und dann gar
nicht vollgepumpt mit antibiotika in
deutschland es 25 prozent des
antibiotika ist was in deutschland
angeboten wird geht an die menschen und
haben manchmal fest 75 prozent geht an
die tierhaltung und es ist auch wirklich
der absolute wahnsinn wenn ich mir das
vorstelle
jetzt wisst ihr auch warum euer arzt zu
euch sagt ihr sollten die hühnersuppe
essen wenn ihr kind krank seid dass wenn
der arzt weiß ganz genau diese jetzt
nicht voll mit antibiotika und die
werden euch
dass antibiotika wird euch auch
irgendwann mal weiterhelfen das würde
die resistent machen und diese wie
gesagt diese hähnchen werden darf
vollgepumpt mit dem ganzen zeug
das ist wirklich meiner meinung nach
geht es mal gar nichts ich bin selber
wirklich jemand der gerne fleisch ist
absolut ich werde auch nicht auf wenn
fleisch zu essen
aber ich bitte euch darum euch mal
gedanken darüber zu machen
ich bin mir sicher wir jetzt 100 100
jahre zurück denkt man ist klar denken
dann denken wir bestimmt mein gott was
für menschen waren wir es damals und ich
mir sicher wenn wir jetzt 50 jahre
vorausdenken und wir später mal
zurückblicken werden auf die zeit in der
wir jetzt leben werden wir sagen wo was
haben wir unseren tieren unsere umwelt
eigentlich damals angetan und ist
einfach viel weniger fleisch auf
qualität wenn ihr in den supermarkt geht
und wirklich ein hühnchen kauft für zwei
euro 30 oder für drei euro 20 oder 330
dann unterstützen natürlich grad so
etwas
ihr bestimmt unterstützt wirklich so
eine sauerei muss ich ehrlich sagen
niemand muss billiges fleisch kaufen ist
einfach weniger also wir daheim essen
jetzt wirklich weniger fleisch ihr könnt
euch auch begann werden finde ich
eigentlich auch mal lustig ich habe
immerhin begann im freundeskreis immer
wenn wir von drei leuten besucht bekommt
es ist ein veganer oder einer zeuge
jehovas einer von beiden ist immer dabei
und ich finde muss ich ehrlich sagen
veganen seien nicht schlecht ich mach
zwei mal witze über veganer aber ich
muss auch ehrlich sagen ich finde es
eine ganz ganz coole einstellung wenn
man sich bewusst ernährt vegan heißt
natürlich nicht immer gleich dass es
gesund ist das sehe ich sehr sehr oft
bei fertigprodukten damit auch bluttat
geschmacksverstärker hefeextrakt alles
rein gehauen finde ich ja auch nicht
toll
naja ist natürlich viel mehr
unverarbeitete lebensmittel und wie
gesagt das was wir unseren tieren
momentan antun ist weder gut für uns
noch für unsere umwelt und wir haben
eine gewisse verantwortung und bitte
bitte achtet darauf und holt euch
wirklich nicht mehr dieses billige
fleisch das ist wirklich widerlich edeka
hat eine ganz tolle aktion vor ungefähr
zwei drei wochen
die haben es wirklich geschafft elika
die haben es wirklich geschafft
100 gramm fleisch für 15 cent anzubieten
das heißt ein kilogramm hühnchen für
für 1 euro 50 das war eine aktion von
den klar haben sie es nicht immer aber
es war ein aktionspreis auch wieder mit
der initiative tierwohl liebe ich habe
das wirklich macht wirklich ein tolles
konzept ich liebe ja wirklich natürlich
globus mehr aber ewig heißt auch cool
ihr habt das wird nicht gar nicht nötig
diesen preiskampf mitzugehen
vor allem beim fleisch und allgemeine
ganzen einzelhändler wieso haut der
eigene euch nicht auf die fresse wenn es
um dinge geht um spaß oder
reinigungsmittel oder glasreiniger oder
irgendein andernorts warum muss es
unbedingt mein fleisch sein waren muss
und nahrungsmittel seien daran gewinnt
nämlich niemand ein landwirt gewinnt nix
unsere umwelt gewinnt nicht der kunde
gewinnt nix und ihr habt doch auch keine
gewinne mehr
also wieso nicht auch bei beispiel mit
euch wirklich mal so richtig einen
reinhauen hier richtig tollen preise zu
gehen oder was eine tolle mehr
ich würde mal gerne das jetzt mal
rasieren wieso habt ihr euch bei raul
rasierklingen ich mal einen drauf
gegenseitig machten einen tollen
preiskampf die finde ich zum beispiel
viel zu teuer aber wirklich bei
lebewesen und bei landwirtschaftlichen
gütern hört der spaß auf
hier gewinnt wirklich niemand mehr und
ich finde es nicht korrekt und ich hoffe
dass edeka das vielleicht ein gesehen
hat und das nicht mehr macht und ich
hoffe natürlich dass er jetzt als als
unsere zuschauer ein bisschen gebrieft
zeit tut euch mal darüber informieren
der deutsche ist im schnitt dass es bis
20 kilogramm geflügel im jahr 20
kilogramm das ist nur der geflügel wir
haben das schwein mit eingerechnet man
mir ist kein schwein
wir haben es winken noch nicht
eingerechnet wir haben fischer und so
zeugt noch nicht eingerechnet
auf jeden fall ist es schon ziemlich
viel bitte ist weniger fleisch isst
dafür qualitativ hochwertiges fleisch 8
auf eur umwelt das ist ganz ganz
wichtige und pastor höre auf und ich
hoffe dass wieder euch gefallen
er war gleich hofelich nicht schockiert
von dem huhn ich wollte euch nur damit
zeigen dass wir inzwischen so weit von
den lebensmittel weg sind gerade von von
von lebewesen das weiß wenn ich böse
gemeint ist dass dem huhn geht es
wirklich gut und diese zwei hühner sind
für den guten zweck gestorben das
lustige an diesen hören ist ich habe die
jungs gefragt ob das wir mit nach hause
nehmen würde
keiner wollte diese hühner mit nach
hause nehmen oder haben habe ich recht
ja das ist wirklich kein huhn dessen für
zwei euro 30 wirklich achten ein
bisschen drauf und die omas war jetzt
aber die kühlkette unterbrochen wird ist
die hühner wegschmeißen es ist wirklich
so ihr könnt mir zwar erzählen
ihr könnt mir zwar erzählen dass sie
vielleicht nicht so viel geld zur
verfügung haben um euch wie soll ich
sagen
biofleisch zu leisten dann ist einfach
weniger wirklich man muss nicht jede
woche fünf sechs mal jeden tag fleisch
haben oder aufschnitt haben das ist
wirklich nicht nötig bevor ich dass wir
noch länger c 15 minuten höre ich jetzt
lieber auf und wir freuen sich um kopf
und kragen redet vielen vielen dank dass
er zugeschaut habe hält mich bitte nicht
dem huhn ist nichts passiert und
vielleicht gibt es einen denkanstoß
vielleicht seite der gleichen meinung
schreibt in die kommentare
wenn der andere meinung seid schreibt
nicht in die kommentare
dann wäre alles für euch ansonsten wir
sehen uns bald wieder minuten und dann
geht es wieder ums kochen backen
versprochen und wir sehen uns macht's
gut
hier war ich weiß es gleich gut werden
wie ich hoffe dass wir natürlich ein
paar menschen wie soll ich sagen
ansprechen ich finds echt auml szlig
wichtiges thema wirklich okay also hätte
ich mich hätte die anderen tschüss ach
ja und was wir dürfen auf dem feuer lege
naja so irgendwie hierzu habe und dann
sind
geht man mit dem orbit nicht bitte ja
vielleicht einfach nur reden bei der cs
gleichen liga von buddy das buddy hat
das huhn seiner oma gebracht die oma
hält hühner also und und verkauft eier
aber nicht schwarz also da ist die
steuer mit begriffen dass ich möchte ich
sagen dass war diese hühnereier verkauft
macht sie nicht macht sie station macht
sie aber nicht verkauft keine hühner nur
für die liga und ist die ihn selber
entscheide ich die allerdings hühner
legen die eier aber die oma ist
besitzerin der hühner auf jeden fall das
ist passiert weil die beatles heraus
okay das ist wir sind ruhig sein ist
einfach ruhig sein einprägsames
unterfangen auch etwas auf zum einen
gefallen tun einfach ich mache ja die
scheiße schon mac okay aber einer fängt
das huhn ein viertel